autres zones sensibles le tchad le tchad
au plusieurs centaines de prisonniers
libyens ont été libérés à l'arrivée des
soldats d'idriss deby idriss déby c'est
l'homme qui vient de faire chuter le
régime d'hissène habré
hissène habré qui contrairement aux
rumeurs de ces dernières heures serait
toujours en vie
l'ancien président tchadien se
trouverait au cameroun l'histoire
récente du tchad n'est qu'une succession
de trahison idriss déby le nouvel homme
fort du pays est un rebelle qui chasse
un autre ancien rebelle hissène habré
une lutte fratricide pour le pouvoir
raconter par gilles rabin
hissène habré souverain du peuple
tchadien après sept ans de pouvoir
absolu le peuple tchadien tourner le dos
à celui qui se voulait son leader
charismatique
c'est un pouvoir absolu s'étend de
trahisons et de meurtres
hissène aura supprimé l'un après l'autre
ses lieutenants ces chefs de guerre trop
populaire à ses yeux
idriss bisquine le héros de faya largeau
hassan djamous ce l'homme de la
reconquête du nord en 82 mahamat itno
tous liquides et après avoir été
longuement torturé parce qu'il risquait
de devenir un jour des concurrents
politiques
seul rescapé idriss deby qui revient
aujourd'hui en vainqueur à djamena
idriss deby devant qui a fui sans
combattre hissène habré que les
tchadiens croyait courageux 34 ans né à
iriba le pays des dresseurs de chevaux
idriss deby est l'inventeur du réseau
mécanisée ses charges de cavalerie
légère aborde toyota un chef de guerre
qui a gagné toutes ses batailles contre
les soldats de kadhafi d'abord contre
les fidèles d'hissène habré ensuite avec
l'appui de kadhafi l'ennemi d'hier formé
par les français diplômé de l'école de
guerre à paris même s'il n'a qu'une
devise ma dignité mon honneur ma parole
idriss déby reste encore un mystère
politique
[Musique]